هؤلاء طلاب جمعتهم لغتهم الروسيه ومحاوله
استيعاب حلم الحياه على الطريقه الامريكيه
يقول اصدقاء واقارب جوهره ساريف انه كان
يعيش كامريكا وكان سهل الاختلاط اما عظمه
تاج ياكوف وتياز كادي بايف الذان قدما من
كازاخستان فقد كان يواجهان صعوبات في
دراستهما وفي التحدث
بالانجليزيه يقول محامي كادي بايف انه
صادق ساريف لانه يتكلم الانجليز بطلاقه
فقد عاش في امريكا لفتره طويله وبحسب
الكسان فقد كان لديهم سياره سوداء لقد
كانت مثيره للاهتمام كانوا يقومون بتشغيل
الاغاني بصوت عال كما كانوا يتسابقون
بالسياره ويستمتعون بذلك مثل كثيرين غيرهم
من الامريكيين كما يؤكد المحامي على انهم
كانوا اشخاصا اجتماعيين فقد كانوا معتادين
على الذهاب الى الحفلات وغالبا ما كانوا
يرقصون ويشربون وتفيد وثائق التحقيقات بان
دياز كادي بايف كان الاقرب لجهر ارناف فقد
كان يذهب الى بيته ويزور اهله كما تشير
المحكمه الى ان عظمه تاجكو ذهب مع
تسارناييف
لضفدع باطلاق الالعاب الناريه ووفق ما
افاد المحامي فقد ابلغ جوهر اصدقائه لانه
يعلم كيف يصنع قنبله وذلك قبل شهر على
تفجيرات ماراثون بوستون ولا توجد اي ادله
لدى الادعاء في الوقت الراهن حول ما اذا
كان الطلاب المعتقلون الثلاثه على علم بما
حدث في بوس
اما الصديق الرابع فيليبوس فقد كان في نفس
الصف مع جوهر بمدرسه كامبريدج عام 2011
والتحق الاصدقاء الاربعه بمدرسه يوماس
دارت ماوث اواخر ذلك العام هذا مقطع فيديو
لفيلبس تم الحصول عليه مما تظن السلطات
الامريكيه انه حسابه على موقع يوتيوب
يتحدث فيه عن
نفسه والان يحاول الثلاثه فهم كيفيه
ارتباطهم بتفجيرات ماراثون بوستون واحتمال
الزج بهم الى داخل السجن